they're really considering shutting down
new year's eve they're trying to cancel
christmas already you've got all the
public health authorities saying don't
go don't go to your families
take 15 tests take a few more jabs don't
maybe just stay home this year for
another 15 days for another what would
this would be the
second christmas that they'll shut us
down it's we're going right into number
three this is going to go on forever and
ever and ever and bill de blasio the
outgoing mayor of new york is saying he
might shut down new year's eve
in times square
so we've been in touch with times square
alliance
we're going to make a decision before
christmas
uh we're certainly looking at
the new challenge we're facing but again
this is an all vaccination event and it
is outdoors and those are two very very
important favorable factors we're also
considering there's other ways we could
approach it even with uh the current uh
the current rules that could help to
make it even stronger so there's a
discussion going on we will have a final
decision on what we can do
ahead of christmas for sure
uh and and we're working very very
closely with the folks respond to the
event to figure out what's the right way
to proceed
so we want to have new year's eve but
maybe maybe we won't now it's already an
all vaccinated event it's already
outside in the fresh air
well as fresh as air gets in new york
which is not very fresh
but we might have to cancel it anyway
so
what was the point
of the lockdowns and the masks and the
vaccines
what was the point the new year's eve
event in times square they've already
said if you're unvaccinated if you're
one of the filthy unwashed masses you're
not allowed to come even though it's
outside even though it's new york which
is just disgusting generally
you're not you're too disgusting for the
streets of new york apparently if you
don't take the vaccine
but they might have to cancel it anyway
i did not realize before i owned a house
back when i was still in little shoebox
apartments living in the cities before i
moved to the south i didn't realize
just how important your window
treatments are and the reason they're
important i should have realized is
because light is so important
when you're filming a podcast for
instance the thing that makes it look
good or look terrible is going to be the
way the light works when you're on a
beach what what makes it it's because of
the light the way the light plays on the
ocean the way the light this is true in
any home in any museum and any church
and it's true in your house too
they have incredible stuff over at
hunter douglas window shade designs
gorgeous fabrics control systems so
advanced they can be scheduled to
automatically adjust to their optimal
position throughout the day maybe it's
the way the shades diffuse the harsh
sunlight to cast that beautiful glow
across the room maybe it's the way they
give you privacy inside
maybe it's the superior insulation the
shades provide you want that goldilocks
fit okay you want hunter ductless's
power view technology head on over today
to hunterdouglas.com
knowles for your free style get smarter
design guide with fresh takes creative
ideas and smart solutions for dressing
your windows that's hunterductless.com
slash knowles kennedwles for your free
design guide this is one of the major
events of the year
we structure our year in events you
think oh christmas that's enough that
helps you put a mark around the year
it's a festival to celebrate easter that
would be another fourth of july that's a
secular holiday but we celebrate and new
year's eve and the most famous new
year's eve celebration in america is the
ball dropping in times square in new
york and they might cancel that
we might put our lives on hold
indefinitely we've already done it for
two years we might just keep doing it
indefinitely
even for the vaccinated and the people
who mask and the most compliant people
so what was the point if you're going to
cancel this stuff anyway why did we do
any of this apparently none of it worked
so why couldn't we just live our lives
and see our families and have our
weddings and go to funerals and go to
holidays
and go to work and keep living why
couldn't we do that if the end result of
all of these measures
is to still keep us all locked up in our
cages
what was the point
point i think the point was political
power for people i don't i don't want to
sound like a conspiracy theorist which
we've we've just learned that conspiracy
theories are spoiler alerts
but there was no
there was no getting back to normal and
now some of the public health officials
are just telling us we're never getting
back to normal we're never going to get
on an airplane without a mask again
we're never going to do any so what was
the point
other than pure political power i'm glad
you like that clip now i need you to
ring that bell you got to subscribe you
got to get the notifications that way
you will never miss an episode and if
you want to get the full show no
censorship no watching what we say
around big tech head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
maybe myspace xanga aol instant
messenger i don't know wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael null show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you